salut romain alors tu es prêt pour le
hellfest mon sac est déjà prêt mais j'ai
un peu peur la peur de quoi j'ai pas
qu'il y ait quelque chose maintenant
t'inquiète va bien se passer
on va parler de la trousse de secours en
plus aujourd'hui non mais je veux dire
qu'il m'arrive un truc avant et que
puisse pas y aller ou [ __ ] c'est vrai
t'as raison
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça y est on est en juin et la saison des
festivals est officiellement ouverte
le hellfest approche à grands pas et si
vous avez suivi mes conseils
votre corps doit être aiguisé comme une
lame et vous avez dû mettre de côté les
accessoires indispensables pour éviter
les ennuis et profiter un maximum
mais il vous reste quelques jours pour
prévoir tout ce qu'il faut pour arranger
les choses si vous en aviez quand même
des données
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous avez compris on va voir tout de
suite ce qu'il faut emporter dans sa
trousse de secours de festivalière et
quels sont les indispensables vous
voulez voyager léger on commence parce
qu'il faut absolument emporté du
paracétamol d'abord doliprane dafalgan
etc vous connaissez eh ben c'est du
paracétamol et c'est un antalgique un
médicament contre la douleur
on est d'accord c'est possible de
rencontrer différents types de douleurs
au festival si vous prenez un coup si
vous fait mal en tombant jamais et pour
tout ce qui est petit bobo type mal de
tête mal de dents etc puis si vous
chauffez un rhume normalement vu la
saison ça devrait aller mais ça fait
aussi baisser la fièvre
juste la fièvre de la maladie un bal
autres fiable des pansements et tout ce
qu'il faut pour nettoyer une plaie en
cas de besoin c'est à dire un
antiseptique et des compresses toute
simple ou des compresses déjà imprégné
d'antiseptiques les compresses toute
prête c'est vrai que c'est pas un idéal
pour l'environnement c'est un peu comme
les largesses mais bon je vous laisse
voir ça avec votre conscience écologique
et donc des pansements un de différentes
tailles déjà tout prêt ou sous forme de
bande à découper et puis si vous êtes
vraiment flipper ou vraiment très
maladroit vous pouvez prendre aussi des
bandes ou des last plast mais
franchement si vous en avez besoin allez
plutôt faire un tour au poste de secours
vos médicaments si vous êtes sous
traitement il faut savoir que si c'est
des médicaments qu'ils gardent au frigo
et que vous en avez pas parce que vous
êtes au camping par exemple et bien vous
pouvez les amener au poste de secours et
ils voulaient garderont offrait à et si
vous êtes asthmatiques
n'oubliez pas votre ventoline même si
d'habitude vous en servez pas là vous
allez respirer quand même pas mal de
poussière donc des préservatifs
1 oui alors vous allez me dire
évidemment pas trop les malins parce que
ce qui va sans dire va quand même
toujours mieux en le disant
et puis vous serez bien content de ne
pas avoir besoin de marcher jusqu'au
leclerc pour aller acheter une boîte vu
que en général
bon c'est sympa mais là un peu de monde
donc si vous en avez besoin à 2 heures
du matin des préservatifs masculins ou
féminins
c'est comme on aime vos protections
menstruel habituel pour les personnes
qui possèdent des menstruations
ah oui c'est comme les préservatifs
c'est évident mais bon hein je vous
serais bien content de les arts sous la
main c'est bien content de les avoir
surtout si ça arrive sans prévenir l
émotion tous à des alcootests
on est d'accord que si vous êtes au
camping à part faire des concours c'est
pas indispensable par contre si vous
devez conduire là oui même si on est
d'accord que normalement vous avez prévu
qu'il ya quelqu'un qui conduit et du
coup qui boit pas un bien sûr ou alors
juste une bière mais bon il ya vraiment
des gens qui arrivent à boire juste une
guerre on ne paraît pas très vite il est
facultatif mais ça peut bien rendre
service
bon s'il vous reste un peu de place dans
votre trousse de secours dans votre sac
et dans votre tante
il ya deux ou trois autres trucs qui
pourrait bien vous sauver la mise du
citrate de bétaïne pour les problèmes de
digestion
on part clairement pas sur du 5 fruits
et légumes par jour ni sur du top
elle fuit pendant tous estivale donc ça
peut servir c'est des comprimés à
dissoudre dans un univers d'eau et à
prendre trois fois par jour avant ou
après les repas en cas de besoin
attention c'est sans ordonnance mais
c'est comme pour tous les médicaments
surtout quand c'est une automédication
jetez un oeil à la notice et parlez-en à
votre pharmacien ou à votre médecin
surtout si vous n'en avez jamais pris un
pour voir si ça vous convient les
allergènes et tout ça une poche de froid
instantané quand on se cogne
quand on prend un coup quand on tombe
quand on se tord la cheville et cetera
pour éviter que ça gonfle le froid rien
mais quand vous aurez pas forcément un
congélateur sous la main les petits
poche sur lesquels on appuie pour
qu'elle vienne très froide
c'est pas mal ça coûte entre 1 et 2
euros pièce et vous pouvez en trouver
dans les magasins de sport
attention les mettais pas directement
contre la peau un les terrains linge
entre les deux sinon ça brûle de la
pommade contre les coups et contre les
hématomes en complément de la poche de
froid vous en recommande pas une marque
en particulier
demandez à votre médecin si vous devez
aller voir ici là ou à votre pharmacien
acheter bien sûr tout ça c'est pour les
bobos minimes 1 si vous avez un truc
méchant ou si vous vous rendez compte
que ça passe pas aller faire un saut au
poste de secours des pipettes de sérum
physiologique
le sérum physiologique c'est de l'eau
purifiée avec un peu de sel ça peut
servir à nettoyer des petites plaies
avant de mettre l'antiseptique mais
c'est surtout l'idéal pour se rincer les
yeux parce que c'est une équipe qui est
très proche des larmes et on en a déjà
parlé vous allez croiser deux trois
nuages de poussière c'est presque sûr de
la biafine alors c'est pas dans les
indispensables parce que vu qu'on en a
déjà parlé dans la vidéo précédente
vous avez pensé à prendre de la crème
solaire pour protéger votre peau mais
s'ils voulaient talent est mal ou que
vous oubliez dans m vous risquez de
choper un coup de soleil
et là vous serez bien content de trouver
votre tube de biafine ou n'importe quel
autre peaux mates du même genre et de
vous en tartiner avant d'aller me
coucher
faites moi confiance a du coup le
lendemain arrangez-vous pour pas exposer
la zone au soleil vous voyez vous mais
les optionnel parce que mon bébé mais
voilà déjà vous êtes bien équipé mais en
fonction de vos petites faiblesses
personnelles de vos talons d'achille
vous aurez peut-être besoin de deux
trois autres trucs un anti moustiques
il ya deux catégories de personnes il ya
celles qui peuvent dormir dans un
marécage donc jamais piqué et celles qui
se font bouffer même si elles passent
leur vie à 24 militaires qui vous fait
partie de la deuxième catégorie
un petit répulsif à appliquer quand la
nuit tombe ça vous évitera de passer
votre temps à vous grattez tous d'avoir
une mauvaise surprise au réveil un
antidiarrhéique parce que on en a déjà
parlé niveau ils viennent de vie ça
risque d'être un peu aléatoire alors si
vous êtes un peu fragile des intestins
et que vous n'avez pas envie que ce soit
le festival aussi dans votre slip c'est
bien le prêt vers le haut surtout que
mon même avec tous les efforts du monde
les toilettes en festival s'est rarement
à l'endroit où on a envie de passer le
plus de temps
il ya plusieurs catégories de
médicaments contre la diarrhée expliqué
bien votre cas à votre pharmacien ou à
votre médecin il vous conseillera celui
qui est le plus adapté pour vous si
c'est un ralentisseur du transit
intestinal
si vous n'avez pas envie de vous
retrouver boucher a qu'un baby pop de
trois jours à la sortie
allez-y mollo
du gel hydroalcoolique
en trois jours il ya pas mal de chances
que vous tripoter deux trois trucs pas
très propre à commencer par vous même et
sans avoir forcément de quoi se laver
les mains du coup une petite giclée de
gel et hop
bye bye les germes évidemment n'oubliez
pas votre trousse de toilette et tout ce
dont on a parlé dans la vidéo précédente
dont je vous remets le lien dans la
description à commencer par la crème
solaire et les protections auditives
voilà si vous avez des petits trucs
perso des petites ips des petits tuyaux
à vous refiler n'hésitez pas à les
donner dans les commentaires on se
retrouve au hellfest pour ceux qui y
vont d'ici là prenez soin de vous prenez
soin des autres mettez vous bien et
surtout pensez bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]